Speaker 1: Speaking of Fox News, one other
just little Fox News story. This this is just
kind of a funny thing. Greg Gutfeld is a Fox
host, and he's going to be taping some shows
in person. And if you want to go and be the
audience, you're going to have to show proof
of vaccination. Now you might be saying,
Well, David, maybe the venue requires it
doesn't appear to be the case. This is very
interesting. Media Matters has this the story?
Gutfeld on his Fox News colleagues have
repeatedly criticized vaccine requirements.
Fox News and host Greg Gutfeld are putting on
a week of shows in Texas that require attendees
to show proof of vaccination or a negative COVID
test. Gutfeld and his colleagues have repeatedly
derided COVID requirements. Fox will be taping
the weekday program Gutfeld at Gilley's Dallas
between February 21 and 25. The event page for
the shows says quote proof of vaccination or
a negative COVID test taken within 48 hours
of the show will be required for admittance.
Some other upcoming shows at Gilley's Dallas
do not appear to have vaccination or testing
requirements for entry, so it is not a requirement
of the state and it is not a requirement of the
venue now. It's fine for them to do this. But why
are they deriding such requirements and measures
constantly on their programs? Gutfeld, like many
of his Fox Corporation colleagues, is vaccinated.
Still, that hasn't stopped the network's
personalities from frequently criticizing
vaccines and attacking pro public health
measures like vaccine requirements. For example,
Gutfeld said last August in New York City, Bill
de Blasio introduced a vaccine passport. The new
passport system calls for showing proof of BACS to
enter gyms, restaurants and entertainment venues,
which, judging by the stats I just mentioned,
effectively bans most blacks just like the Dems
did to them during the Jim Crow days. So who
is the Hitler now? If 70 percent of black New
Yorkers are unvaccinated, they're the ones
getting banned. Talk about white privilege,
folks. How do you take these people seriously
when they're telling people COVID protocols
are bad and discriminatory? And then they
choose to enact the very same COVID protocols,
the very same COVID protocols that they say are
racist in some cases. And then there's the state
of Texas doesn't require it. Gilley's Dallas
doesn't appear to require it because other
shows don't have these requirements. But the
Gutfeld show requires it, and I agree with it.
I agree with it. But the important point here is
not only are they hypocrites, they are hypocrites
in a way that is bad for public health until it
affects them personally. Gutfeld probably doesn't
want to be around unvaccinated people. It could be
as simple as that at the end of the day that this
comes down to. It's just pathetic. It's pathetic,
and I don't think that they're going to change.
They're going to continue saying what they need
to say to placate their audience. But then doing
what they know they actually need to do to be
safe and to keep themselves safe. Not surprising